season five
not just for Aria but for the whole
story is a very strong one she makes a
big change very early on and Tommy she
sure who played Jack and her guy is
gonna be returning looking forward to
working with him again that's been
rumored yes what do you think the
chances though we'll see you again on
the show I think I'd like to stage a can
and comeback tumbler to show you played
Jack and Hegar might be coming back to
the show you what do you think about
that I know it doesn't happen in the
books but it makes perfect sense for a
TV audience to - for him sanity to go
hello it's me again he is the one who
gave her the coin and the last thing we
saw was that that bargain that deal was
being made what would you like to see
happen next for pot embryo I would just
love to see more poor than Brienne
getting to know each other and Brienne
realizing pods useful not useless I
would be great if you know they they did
find Sansa that'd be really nice she
becomes fan of this woman who really
realizes that the world is not a fairy
tale life is not a fairy tale
she's probably the most pessimistic
character on the show from now on
because she knows everything
and she knows that she can't trust
anyone I mean look how much is not
Littlefinger she she is so wise now it's
different than my new normal kind of
environment LeBron
so it was actually it was nice to shake
it up would you like Meryn trant's gets
Enoch see kill rod just kill Ron I like
to kill favor the King Stannis means
well he's got his own agenda
you never saw sir al-assad I injured yes
dragged away so don't be surprised if
you see him again and don't be surprised
if he's still a lone wolf I've got five
episodes in the next series I have
things to do with the mountain how much
would you like to fight the Hound
if felt being next season yes if I will
I would like to fight him aaden's
characters gone off now but it would be
nice to see them sort of join back
together that would be really cool to
see him sort of have a bit of more of a
political role and in in in King's
Landing and to do with with the the
battle for the throne I think it would
be really fascinating and Gendry
hopefully we're gonna see him because
we've missed him for a whole season ever
exactly yeah Joe wrote a really funny
stay as last year like a tweet just
saying still Rowan and I love that so
yeah Ganges just still Rowan about
somewhere but I think we will see him
again we have to see him again
he's such an iconic you know after
episode 2 of season 3 I think we
realized a lot about him
and that he's very very powerful person
and he doesn't really know it yet so
either he's gotta turn it around and you
know he used himself or someone else is
gonna manipulate part of the idea behind
having ganges of drift off for a little
while is so that you know well and if
the return is made it it makes it all
the more impactful I think you know you
need he needs to have been given time to
to experience certain things and turn to
therefore change in a significant enough
way